[Music]
well just days before MP's votes on the
Prime Minister's plan the brexit Select
Committee has released a highly critical
report on the deal it sounds the plan
fails to offer sufficient clarity or
certainty about the future and to resume
most proposals are neither details and
nor substantive and chair of that
committee is Labour's Hilary ban who
joins us now so what exactly has your
committee found
well good morning Sophie we've agreed
unanimously a report now we are a
committee made up of people who can't
paint passionately for remain and for
leave during the referendum but as you
yourself have said we were promised a
detailed and substantive political
declaration our future relationship we
haven't got one it all it offers is
uncertainty about the future and the
only thing we know for sure is the terms
on which we will leave but if you're a
business looking five years ahead ten
years and you ask the question so how's
trade going to work what will happen to
services which is 80% and the British
economy the honest answer is you don't
know because nobody knows and we also
say that the government has failed to
make the choices that it will eventually
have to make about how we trade off the
different things that we want because
the government's proposals per Ford in
checkers were rejected by the EU we say
that Canada wouldn't work it wouldn't
solve the problem of Northern Ireland it
wouldn't insure the continuation of
friction free trade which is so
important to the British economy as we
know that's why there's concern about
what would happen at Dover Calais
Eurotunnel if we were to leave with no
deal we also observe as a community that
we think there isn't likely to be a
majority in the House of Commons for
leaving with no deal and that's
something that we will test as part of
the vote on amendments on Tuesday and
we've you've been the chair committee
for and some time now we're now onto the
third Barroso secretary we're gonna be
hearing from one of the former brexit
secretaries don't rob a little bit later
on the show and one thing that seems to
have come out from the previous brexit
Secretary's is that they feel that they
had went probably listen to you weren't
probably involved shall we say in some
of those negotiations do you
there's been a problem in how the
negotiations been carried out look I
think any Prime Minister is going to
want to be directing what have been the
most important negotiations that the
country is engaged in for decades and
you know the dynamic between a prime
minister and camera notices as I know
from my own experience in the end the
Prime Minister is going to want to
decide what's going to happen but I hate
a nation but I think there's everywhere
I think there's a much more fundamental
problem which has been for two years the
cabinet was Riven with disagreement it
was arguing amongst itself about what
even to ask for when we would meet
Michel Barney he would say could you
please tell us what it is you want as a
country that's the first problem and
second problem is I think the
government's been honest with the
British people about the choices we have
to make because the other thing we say
in our report today is the degree of
access we're going to have in future
will depend on the extent to which we
are prepared to follow the rules of the
people with whom we are trading now that
is a trade off that is a choice and I'm
afraid that the story of brexit has been
for too long
the impression was given oh don't worry
we can get everything we want we can get
rid of the things that we don't want and
now finally people have realised that is
not true and if you listen to those who
argued for brexit they don't actually
have a plan is it is it Canada is it
leaving with no deal and not paying
people who back remain hardly have a
plan either some of them say that we
should respect the result of the
referendum others say that they want a
second referendum others are talking
about a Norway option which one do you
want to see it's easy to criticize other
people isn't it for not having I
respected the outcome the referendum I
voted to trigger article 50 but it's
quite clear that the deal with the prime
ministers brought back is not going to
succeed i dint forget offer certainty
and the amendment that I've put down for
next Tuesday as well as rejecting the
Prime Minister's deal also says the
House of Commons rejects Lima win No
Deal and I think that is really
important because the two Pitt props of
the Prime Minister's argument have been
well it's either my deal or its leaving
with no deal if Parliament with one vote
says well neither of those is acceptable
then I think it puts pressure on the
government to move my own view is that
it would be more sensible to go for
membership of the
in a customs union but if we cannot
reach agreement on that if Parliament
remains deadlocked then in the end we're
going to have to resolve this one way or
another and it is just possible that the
only way that can be achieved is by
going back to ask the people again but
do you think as a parliamentary majority
for the EAA this Norway plus option
staying in the single market and a
customs you well that has yet to be
tested
honest answer Sophie is I don't know I
don't think anybody does
there clearly those in the government
who would choose to move in that
direction if and when the government and
the Prime Minister's deal is rejected
Labour's policy of course is to want to
stay in a customs union to have a close
relationship with a single market which
is pretty close to that but none of that
is ideal because the the fundamental
weakness in all of these things is you
are following rules over which you have
no say and also in the EA you would also
have to accept premium to people which
is a big tribe so that is why it is true
but I said in my speech in that comes
last week in the end though either
everyone is going to have to compromise
because nobody is going to get
everything they want out of this process
the trouble is our politics has become
more polarized but there is a strong
inbuilt British desire to seek
compromise where it is possible but
we'll have to see whether the House of
Commons would be prepared to back that
and I wanted to ask you about your
amendment you mentioned Italia which
effectively rules out the PM's deal that
walls out no deal but I'm right in
saying on time that if that amendment
goes forward people would necessarily
how to vote on the Prime Minister's deal
at all well if it if it were to be
carried then it becomes what's known as
the substantive amendment and you can
have a second vote on it if you want but
if it is carried it would say Parliament
is rejecting the Prime Minister's deal
it would have so you wouldn't be voting
on the Prime Minister's heel so you'd be
letting off the hook a bit then weren't
you well no because if Parliament votes
to reject the Prime Minister's deal in
votes to reject the parameters deal that
is not letting the Prime Minister off
the hook that is telling her I'm afraid
your deal won't what at the same time it
would be significantly more difficult
for the Prime Minister if she put this
motion to the house and motion she's
worked on for more than two years
and it was decisively rejected well it
wouldn't that be well no I think in the
end if Parliament says with one vote on
the amendment that's got cross-party
support people from all parties if
Parliament says we don't approve your
deal but crucially we do not approve of
leaving the European Union with no deal
I think we have a not lose that vote by
as many as she would lose that is that
is that is possible because a lot of
people are on her own back pensions
would not support your Amendment indeed
because some of them think you can leave
with no deal now I'm very clear and if
you look at the evidence the assessments
that have been done the warnings from
County Council talked to business never
mind what politicians say about the
impact of no deal just talk to business
as we have done taken evidence as a
committee I have done and ruling out
leaving with no deal now I think is
really important for the future of the
country because otherwise you prolong
the uncertainty I don't think there's a
majority in the House of Commons for
leaving with no deal I don't actually
think the government would be foolish
enough to say okay we are leaving with
no deal so why carry on pretending let's
give Parliament the chance to say
clearly we reject your deal we also
reject no deal and then other
possibilities well over them so even if
it saves the Prime Minister from afar
heavy defeat you're not going to be
withdrawing your amendment no I think
Parliament have given the chance to
reject no deal because I think a
cross-party member has a chance it may
be that all of the amendments go down
and the Prime Minister's deal is also
defeated one cannot predict what the
House of Commons will decide we are a
democracy well that is certainly true if
a recent weeks runs into go by a Hillary
band thank you very much
you
[Music]